these the season numbers for luzardo
again in those four starts it's been
some uh some rough outings in there for
sure
this one is hit in the air out toward
left center field not even going to get
to the track
and brinson puts it away
[Applause]
2-1 coming
and a ground ball right side that's jazz
from the outfield grass
makes the play to alfaro
escobar to third and there are two away
and he gets him to chase that change up
as well the strikeout for luzardo in the
first works around the double
marlins come to bat next eric fetty
so four starts against miami you talked
about the ownage 0.84 2-0
he starts the wind up
and the pitch fastball in there strike
three call perfect pitch
knee high outside corner at 96 miles an
hour
there goes jazz the pitch is swung on
and miss a throw down to second is not
on time and jazz almost over slid but he
was able to hang on to the bag and
umpire joe west was right on top of that
a stolen base for jazz and it's number
14.
but he was running on a breaking ball as
well the question is did he come off but
i don't think that he did
delivers an o2 to brinson reach for a
breaking ball and skies at the center
thomas shooting right center there
coming up on it makes the catch
chisholm will hold it second as the
throw comes in two men away
he's all over the strike zone
he's only thrown four balls in this game
and a pretty good job of pitching around
the error
so a scoreless first
nets had the only hit and the series is
underway
lined and caught by jazz
a leaping play at second base to take a
hit away from kibum and that ball might
have been ticketed for the gap too
hernandez at third and garcia the runner
at first two balls two strikes and two
outs to fetty
and that is caught behind the second
base bag by miguel rojas soft little
liner
and luzardo gets out of trouble in the
second
got a good breaking ball going another
hitter lunging
fair or foul it's foul and ryan
zimmerman runs it down
he made that look easy
look at this
find the baseball
still got wheels over the shoulder not a
problem
good hustle he was the only one in sight
didn't have to worry about a crash
not a problem i like how he holds his
glove there for just a click like
soto lines one to left then brinson is
able to go down and get it throw goes to
first it's cut off but a great play
by lewis brinson on a sinking line drive
off the bat of juan soto and you wonder
if the lights had a little something to
do with this his reaction time he kind
of froze just to make sure he knew where
it was going of course slicing just a
bit off the bat
great job on the recovery full extension
leaves his feet
very nice catch
lefty the lefty here the next pitch is
hit on the ground at the first base side
and fair past the lunging alfaro and
down the line it'll be extra basis for
hernandez over to pick it up in the
corner is sanchez
yadiel's rounding second he's heading
for third the throw there from chisholm
is too late
it's a sliding triple for yada yada
hernandez
and the nationals in business in the top
of the fourth now trace pereira with one
out
gotta pitch up knew what to do with it
see
you
later
[Applause]
second for trace pereira
10 rbis two nothing nets
i think he got a hanger up
loud sound big contact
and getting a lot of high fives in the
nationals dug out
there's garcia with a bouncer
he's gonna make the turn and keep on
going
looks like he's okay and the nats have
almost hit for the cycle in the last
three batters
advance the runner and so now thomas
will try to bring him in
up the middle
garcia around to score and lane thomas
continues
his great hitting and now the nats have
hit for the cycle here in the fourth
inning
he drives that ball
loud and long the other way it hits off
the base of the wall
and because the bounce came in quickly
there might be a play at third and
they've got him
jesus sanchez
the key to that play was it hit the wall
on the fly
carried back to the nets in a hurry
marlin's first run 90 feet away
oh he's going to get the call on a pitch
off the corner eric fetty has seven
strikeouts in four innings zimmerman has
been up twice he has struck out twice
ryan zimmerman
see
you later
oh my
fell behind o2
his 12th of the year
five nothing nationals
little change up here to ryan and just
golfs it out here look at the roll of
the wrist low liner
and 40 career home runs against one ball
club
oh man look at that career high for eric
fetty and strikeouts 10 k's pitch hitter
for the marlins is aguilar
trailing by five the marlins are looking
for a big swing right here to get him
back into it
and it's a line drive base hit
not scoreless anymore alfaro is going to
come in to score another rbi for jesus
aguilar pinch hit single and it's 5-1
machado a strike away from finishing off
the bottom of the seventh
de la cruz at third aguilar at second
the one-two pitch
strike three called fastball 97 over the
outside corner perfect pitch for machado
blocks up rojas
thomas escobar and soto the runners
third to first
one two from mitchell
is
a hot shot to second and jazz gets to it
and they turn the double play
what a pick by jazz to start the 4-6-3
double play
and get mitchell and the marlins out of
trouble tonight
so now we go bottom nine anderson alfaro
and de la cruz
for the marlins against cal finnegan
looked like a change up and he struck
him out nats win it in three hours in 16
minutes 5-1 the count